yes so what how did your journey go to
like I don't know if I want to call it a
journey but like what was like what like
role has religion like played in your
life and stuff because um you know I
think as we're at a time in the world I
think in just in I think we're always at
a time in the world but I think we're it
feels like a lot of people are looking
for something that makes sense more I
feel like we're getting
exhausted like by the truth that a lot
of the things that we feel like will
make us feel good aren't doing it you
know
um I feel like that a lot of times but
um yeah what what what has some of that
experience been like I mean if you got
baptized they really how what kind of uh
and was it like a what are they doing in
what do they baptize you in water oh
yeah yeah good
huh oh here's your video right here oh
yeah oh it's pretty there
[Music]
huh upon your profession of faith in the
Lord Jesus Christ and in obedience to
his Divine command I baptize you my
sister in the name of the father and the
son and the holy spirit amen oh
congratulations thanks I still get teed
when I see that that's cool it's
powerful yeah yeah how what what is that
like in your
life yeah
um what's it like how do you get there
like how do you get cuz I think a lot of
people are lost I feel lost a lot of
times you know I think a lot of us feel
that way and so how do you feel like you
solved like you're lost um well I mean
or is that even a fair question I don't
know yeah I know I get what you're
saying I I was brought up with um
Christianity in in my childhood and and
then I strayed and uh so like in a
nutshell I just kind of in The Last 5
Years have like made my way back and
have a a different understanding than
maybe when I was a kid because I think
when you're a kid you're like or at
least for me it was like we just go to
church because that's what we have to do
and um you know I don't I didn't
have actual profound questions that I I
want answered like I do now and so I
think as an adult you get to have a
different understanding of that and so
that that's kind of what you know how I
in a a weird artsy way just kind of came
back and I just the last five years have
just been St the Bible and um and now
like at this church like we have our
Women's Bible study and stuff that I
that I attend and um and have a meeting
you go to right I I watched another
podcast that you were on oh yeah yeah oh
yeah um I heard you talk about it anyway
that you guys have a Bible study each
week yeah yeah um and you know I think
I'm I'm going to always have questions
and continue to want to learn and have
deeper understandings of things and so
but I in that podcast that you probably
watched like I talk about like a little
bit what you you said it's like we're
trying to find meaning or um want to
feel again you know and I think there's
a lot of temporary fixes or you know um
like you know I used to like I was an
addict and you know I'm so I'll have a
17 years sober in July wow and so you
know I think I feel like those are all
things that kind of like lead you in
that in that direction and yeah I think
you know it's such an intimate and
personal thing like my relationship with
God is
my own and um and I I've never really
felt like I belonged anywhere um
like especially now I think like being
public with my faith um puts you into
like this
microscopic um critical tank you know
and so I get criticized from from all
sides now which I don't care because at
the end of the day I I'm you know my
relationship's with with God not you but
right but it is interesting I feel like
now it just becomes funny like some of
the comments I get yeah I think because
people have a hard time understanding
the aesthetic and pairing that with
something which is your aesthetic you
mean yeah right the Ambiance of you and
then comp and then pairing it in
Christianity and it's so silly to me and
like I I don't understand how people
don't see how um close-minded that is
you know and how like yeah why would you
think that you have to look a certain
way to to have an understanding of the
Bible you know yeah or you know yeah
that's a good point too I think it's all
well a lot of that there's a lot of
interest and stuff there you know yeah
like like I do but you know so I mean
there's a lot to think about in all of
this yeah for sure you know like one
time I went to like a Jordan Peterson um
uh lecture and my husband and I were
like the only people that looked like us
there um but I was black people you mean
what you mean black people
no I just like and I don't want want to
diss on like Jordan's fan base but I
feel like there everybody had their own
uniform you know like there was just
rows of people in front of me and they
all kind of dress the same really yeah
and I was like man for some for people
who and I'm not again not judging or
criticizing but you would think that
like free free thinkers would I or maybe
they just don't care I don't know like
so the church I go to is like a really
small church and it's it's there's not
enough people to have a a running trend
or anything like that but when I went to
like a big church in California recently
I looked around and it's like a lot of
people have the same same style and so I
realized that maybe because um like
modern day Christians are so used to
being surrounded by people that look the
same as them when someone like like me
comes into the mix it's like oh wait
this is demonic or this is because I get
called demonic a lot or um or this is
like you know you're serving two masters
and I'm like I I don't think any of that
is accurate you know I don't think you
have to there's no dress code to to be a
Christian there like um oh that's
baffling to me yeah but I get it a lot
like I just recently posted this the
like my last post was just a I thought
was like a very cool like modest image
of me like in a in a dress and some
funny shoes and I just oh the comments
are just hilarious it's just people like
Satan's going to bring you home and just
things that's
crazy y I guess there's all levels of
everything like even if you get into
like the Christian like if you like like
I thought I was going to get hate from
my existing fans you know like just
people who are like feel like you could
be a deserter or something or maybe
people that are fans of yours that uh AR
don't have a religion or aren't
Christians or something that they would
have a thought about it and no they've
been super loving and open-minded and I
love that you know but yeah it's been
the other the other side that I was just
so surprised but wow yeah you know
that's it's like
I think there's a lot of like
interesting stigmas with Christianity I
guess like I I like religion right I
like um I don't know if I care what
religion people are yeah you know I I
think I wish I knew more about some of
the religions you know um I probably
prefer Christianity for myself yeah
because that's what I know the most yeah
and but or I would say that I prefer
that's that's the term I like to use and
most of my belief
started um through AA through Al through
going to 12ep meetings it was like the
first time I ever like started to get
like an understanding of um like
starting to build a relationship with
God and talking to God and feeling like
that if I think or feel something that
there's something on the other side of
the universe that hears it or cares
about it right um and that it blew my
mind dude
because you know I've been like I've
been electrocuted a couple times
whatever oh yeah but I never uh had a
feeling like this it's not like being
electrocuted it's just like feeling like
wait what what do you mean you you've
been electrocuted yeah yeah I've been
electrocuted dude I've been electrocuted
yeah I mean not I guess a handful of
times or whatever yeah yeah I guess one
time I got electrocuted at a carnival
when I was young I got elect oh four
three years ago I stepped on I was
walking behind a h a t uh food truck and
I stepped they had a plugin a big joint
plugin and I stepped right on it and
just it
just you
know I wasn't it was like the opposite
of being baptized I think it was not it
was uncomfortable yeah I like thinking
about God I love thinking about it now I
don't have a lot of people on that are
that I guess that we talk about it with
as much I'm probably the worst person
cuz I'm not like a studied you know oh I
don't know anything about like the
history of it I mean I know that the you
know I know about the family in the
woods I know they had the Apple I know
one of the sons killed the other one so
things got a little hectic right out of
the gate you know but uh but there's a
lot of like the spec I don't know a lot
of the logistics you know yeah so I
think I wouldn't yeah that part I don't
know about yeah but I just think about
feelings and stuff yeah I like thinking
about that kind of stuff like I think
about like the story of Job in the Bible
like um that one is you know even if you
look at it um you know not literally
like where like job was this guy and I'm
going to just paraphrase it obviously
totally paraphrase and look if anybody
judges somebody for paraphrasing out of
the Bible dude we're not pastors you
know yeah yeah for sure yeah we're just
two people sitting somewhere trying our
best to be alive in the universe yeah
yeah it's true but thanks um but you
know like job was put through all these
trials and all the worst things that you
could imagine happening to one person
and through he just maintained his faith
and even at at a point where even at at
one point his wife was like come on are
you serious like how can you still like
praise God when you you know you're
losing your children you're losing
everything we've had you know and um now
you're sick and covered in boils and on
the brink of death you know and he was
just like praise God you know and I feel
like a lot of times you know through my
Decades of tattooing people and hearing
like the worst and saddest stories like
yeah just you know I I I was kind of
known for a lot of portraits and so I
would do portraits of people um their
loved ones who have passed or you know
their loved ones who inspired them
things like that and you just hear some
of the most heart-wrenching stuff that
like I can't even begin to imagine like
how you're still walking you know but um
but they still find a way you know and I
feel like that's like I want to be like
job in that sense you know because like
this the like the last few years for me
have been so rough like behind the
curtains you know I don't share all my
I'm not the type of person that goes on
Instagram and cries you know but it's
like you know we we suffer quietly
through things and we like um you know
no one's no one has a perfect life and
um but I'm still going to live in a
state of gratitude you know and I'm
still going to be like excited to be
here sitting with you today you know and
it's like the the world could be falling
apart and I'm still like I praise God
you know yeah um yeah it gives you hope
I think yeah that's the thing I think
that's I don't know I mean yeah I love
that
yeah and we do all s it is interesting
how we suffer quietly huh yeah I mean
some some suffer loudly like a dick but
oh yeah like my freaking neighbor's dog
that think's not even suffering and
uh but it's loud yeah
um but it's all going to be okay yeah I
think that's what God is to a lot of
people it's a it's a
real it's a it's like I would way rather
have hope me too
than to not have it yeah that's the
thing it's
like and yeah I don't know I've just
felt God I've just felt God like same I
didn't it was the only thing I could say
it was yeah you know cuz one time I was
smoking a bunch of menthols actually
going back to cigarettes but my
girlfriend had broken up with me and I
was about to just you know peel my skin
off of my body and feed it to something
and I wasn't doing real well and I was
just really doing real bad just on the
inside I was just and I just I mean I
swear this is crazy but I felt like
something literally just like put like a
like a big hand went around my heart and
I started to feel better um but I felt
like a it really felt like that which is
same yeah I had the exact same feeling
yeah it was weird and I don't really
talk about it because then you sound all
like oh I don't give a [__] people know
I'm B you know we're doing our best if
anybody thinks yeah that they they think
I know anything about God like any exact
low-key BTS information about the lord
they're out of their fing mind and if
they think they do too then they're out
of their fing mind I just am trying to
think out loud and feel out loud with
somebody yeah is that what that but you
had something similar yeah yeah where I
felt like like a hand like just kind of
um wrapping me in warmth and um and I
just I just uh had this feeling of
surrendering to it you know where I was
just like oh man like it's it's going to
be fine it's not it's not me just being
like Oh tell myself until like you know
like no like I had I had like a a clear
understanding that like you got me you
know yeah it's kind of
cool